welcome to this video playing Oliver hmm
what ever eaten Oliver eaten okay from
from Spain we have a queen Queen spawn
Toro check hmm yeah yeah I usually play
it with b6 trying to get a position like
this style of the head shock okay well
yeah I can i can get the bishop maybe I
should do that you played played a quick
commercial g3 ok now it's the best spot
to take it so he cannot use the edge
from
yeah I have the two bishops always nice
to have but not so easy to make progress
yeah this is a MOOC that I have feared
not not like it's endangering black so
much but it poses a question if I want
to preserve the bishops I need to play d
5 which does not look like a very
attractive muth because it makes the
special really bad yeah but if I
exchange it's it's a very very lame
position okay I'll do that and now let's
see what's what's a plan i can go for a
five okay let's strengthen the control
over a five so i probably missed this a
six bomb
okay yeah he always attacks the pond and
it's not so easy I probably need to do
this to to make to make this pieces
mobile I cannot defend a 6 all the time
I'd also i need to get some counter play
on the Kings on the queenside he will he
will get some sort of a tech going g4g
three kingi to some some something like
that right okay at least yeah at least
he was provoked to to a move here nice
playing this really quickly Queen d3
half g six
you have this queen is offside it really
is and just look might swing over
Wow if it takes Queen takes the screen
g7 to defend this okay return just
returned trying to do ya don't mind you
to trade some some stuff don't want to
get checkmated here on the King side and
then endgame is of course something I'd
like to play with the with the bishops I
know the a8 Bishop is not looking like
like a fantastic piece but it will be
improved
and I have this display let's play
against them f to catching up a bit
timewise but not not much here you will
give this check here
ah check
taking a five Bishop g6 em he can
probably play Bishop g6 am what the heck
is this guy doing to me here what the
heck check
yeah check 50s 50 seconds okay so at
least I'm not meeting mated now I think
this looks everything's everything's
protected and I'm going on dark squares
yourself it should be okay
attending creek and a keg ok it didn't
check but you can go to age too ok check
Queen takes Queen takes the threatening
Queen g1 made it's probably stronger he
does not have a check here reform queen
edge from it checkmate Wow boy you
really played this very strong very
strong who I'd what's always dangerous
when Carol the computers completely
unimpressed giving black almost winning
edge yeah okay it's two bishops I know
but it's still it's very tricky to play
Jack may be here it wants to go bush or
b6 maybe this is better check yeah I
this better not know this is dangerous
and here probably I should lose somehow
I this fridge yeah he took them okay
check this is this is Jenny this is
winning Jack yeah I cannot interpose
with the Queen chantier he gets he gets
all the pawns if I go go here check
check I'm even going to get me to turn
check check
checkmate yeah it was that was that was
a real check check we lucky win check
wrong chair the worst is over i have i
have some coordination and yeah yeah
yeah here it is probably good again wow
that was really tough check damn check
chechen that that's a win I was just
thinking seeing it here I could have
gone down here it's not clear how i win
when now I probably need to cover here
like like this it's not mmm yeah this
kind of endgame can can be tricky but I
think I can just I can just go here I am
the bishop should be able to stop the
two pawns I cannot stop but make sure
that he needs enough time or should I go
here it's not so clear if this is a win
it goes here not him okay thanks for
watching